triste record pour l'inde le pays d'asie
du sud a dépassé ce lundi la barre des
50 mille décès dus aux coronavirus plus
de 900 personnes en sont mortes au cours
des 24 dernières heures selon le
ministère de la santé indien le pays
compte aussi 2,6 millions de cases
officiel de kovy de 19 ce qui en fait la
troisième nation par le nombre de
contaminations mais le taux de dépistage
est en faible les experts considèrent
que ces chiffres sont sous-estimés
ce week-end lors de la fête de
l'indépendance le premier ministre s'est
voulu optimiste en inde
pas un pas deux trois vaccins sont à des
phases de test différente lorsque nous
recevrons le signal vers des
scientifiques
il sera produit à grande échelle en inde
le confinement a été levé en juin mais
des mesures de restriction ont été
réinstaurée depuis dans certains états
de plus en plus de pays réagissent ainsi
à un rebond épidémique du coronavirus la
nouvelle zélande qui compte pourtant peu
de cas a décidé de reporter d'un mois
les élections législatives prévues le 19
septembre
le coc vis de la nouvelle normalité
mondiale ici en nouvelle zélande nous
travaillons tous aussi dur que possible
pour nous assurer que notre nouvelle
normalité perturbe le moins possible nos
vies je sais que l'incertitude créée par
le cos vide est incroyablement difficile
cependant et pour tout le monde nous
sommes tous dans le même bateau et je
tiens donc à vous assurer que je n'ai
pas l'intention de modifier à nouveau la
date des élections
l'archipel avait réalisé un exploit
aucun nouveau cas n'avait été enregistré
pendant 102 jours mais depuis le début
du mois d'août les contaminations
reprennent mais c'est en amérique latine
que la progression du virus reste la
plus inquiétante
la colombie a franchi le seuil des 15
mille morts c'est le quatrième pays
d'amérique latine en nombre de décès
et en nombre de cas le pérou lui a
annoncé ce dimanche avoir enregistré
plus de dix mille nouveaux cas en 24
heures un record et la bolivie affirme
avoir dépassé les cent mille
contamination en qu'ovide 19
tout comme l'équateur au total en
amérique latine plus de 6 millions de
contaminations ont déjà été enregistrées